i'm actually not going to be covering
yesterday's mass shooting in san jose
california
because i have quite literally nothing
to say about it that's new and what i
mean by that is
it's another shooting we've had like a
dozen in the last week or so
we have no political will in this
country to do something about gun
violence not all of us but because
republicans have so much power
they don't want to do anything about it
you have a movement which wants
more guns out there every single time
there's a mass shooting
and i can't think of anything to say
since we've covered so many of these
shootings but there is an
ancillary story related to yesterday's
shooting
that i do want to cover retired new york
police department detective pat brosnan
was invited on fox news to comment on
yesterday's mass shooting and he
bizarrely
blamed coronavirus vaccination
for the shooting and said you can bet
the shooter himself was vaccinated now i
couldn't believe this was possibly
an actual analysis being made by a real
guest on fox news
one of the three major cable news
networks in the united states but it
happened
let's jump right in and you will quickly
see that pat brosnan appears to have
something not functioning quite right in
his brain
good morning harris uh actually uh in a
in a rational world
where there's adherence to the rule of
law and respect for law enforcement
say pre uh the summer of love of 2020
i think there would be more uh nuanced
response in terms of
opening a shooting an active shooting
right next door to where there's a load
of armed
professional shooters under law
enforcement but the rules have changed
you know crimes are no longer illegal
there's no longer enforcement of lots of
laws and
there's an empowerment of these active
shooters so first of all
how could a former police officer make
such a silly analysis if people still
respected law enforcement
no mass shooter would even think to
start shooting near a police station
the shooter planned to die what does he
care
if there are police nearby and what does
pat brosnan mean
crimes are no longer illegal by
definition crimes are
illegal acts but is he saying we no
longer prosecute
crimes just from hearing this part it
was off to a bad start
but then he gets into vaccination and
you know harris this is a time that i
wish i was wrong with my
prediction which i mentioned to anybody
who listened
that once uh once covert starts to lift
these cowardly shooters uh will come out
exactly in tandem with the number of
vaccinations you can be sure they
probably got vaccinated
they were just scared to come out and
they're coming back and you see the
numbers don't lie
the shootings are up dramatically
skyrocketing actually
on on active shootings throughout the
united states as we've come
through this uh pandemic it's really
terrifying stuff
you know pat as we listen to that very
brief news conference one of the things
that i picked up on
so the host there harris faulkner
has nothing to say about this absurd
hypothesis
he says look mass shootings are
increasing as vaccinations increase
mass shootings are increasing as people
are gathering in groups publicly again
pat brosnan is acting like his
prediction was notable in some way
i've been saying on this show many
others have said
we are seeing mass shootings increase
again as
things are reopening mass shootings are
standard operating procedure in the
united states
sadly tragically disgustingly when
people go back to work
when people go back to commuting when
people go back to socializing as we
exit the pandemic there have been and
will be more mass shootings
it's not vaccination and at the end he's
really off the deep end because he says
i bet you this shooter was vaccinated
first of all at this point
everybody should be vaccinated and what
i mean by that is
we've had more vaccine supply than
demand for more than six weeks now most
of those who aren't currently vaccinated
they're not necessarily anti-vaxxers but
they've not yet been determined enough
to go and get a vaccine because they
could have done
it okay but he seems to be suggesting
that the shooter was waiting to get
vaccinated
before doing the mass shooting the
shooter appears to have planned to die
yesterday
if you plan to either shoot yourself or
get police to shoot you
after shooting up your workplace why are
you waiting for the vaccine
maybe you want for your workers to be
co-workers to be back at work so that
you can have a bunch of them together to
shoot okay yeah that may be something
you're waiting for
but what a completely hair brained idea
and this is by far the stupidest way
i've seen to criticize vaccines
uh from from the entirety of this
pandemic if there has ever been a
cautionary tale
about understanding the difference
between correlation and causation
it's looking at an example like this
mass shooters
are not notoriously fastidious about
being vaccinated before going out and
doing a mass shooting
it there's just we that that's not the
case and then it's also important to
mention
implicit in his argument is that
coronavirus shutdowns
are good in terms of they limit mass
shootings
my guess is this is not a guy who is too
thrilled with coronavirus guidelines
just from how he talks dismissively
about vaccination
but what he seems to be saying is when
we were quote
locked down which we never were it
actually did work to decrease mass
shootings which is an interesting thing
to hear from a guy
who is making no sense about any of his
arguments disgusting
sick argument to be making if you ever
feel
like you just don't have enough time to
read all the books you want
to read you have to check out one of my
favorite apps
called blinkist blinkist takes thousands
of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book or audiobook
that you can get through in just 15
minutes where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important
insights from 10 different books in an
afternoon obviously it's perfect for
exposing yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read
it i recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video